the jurogan experience did you see dc's
breakdown
and in detail uh the second fight versus
the first fight
with connor very interesting it is but i
see a lot of people talking funny stuff
about like
the leg kick didn't knock him out what
happened like so dc says in the detail
breakdown
uh i kick conor's calf and conor steps
back and his leg kind of goes
and dc says well that's the leg kick
that you know hurt his leg or whatever
but
when he went after that leg kick he kind
of reached down to grab the foot and
threw an uppercut
and i was switch stand so i threw a
cross from my backhand that clipped him
good
and that's when he took the step back
and was hurt um i think that's a detail
people are missing
that right hand well you certainly you
landed a lot of solid shots in that
fight
but there's no doubt that leg kick was
[ __ ] that right leg up
for sure but the detail what i was gonna
get over is the the difference between
the first fight and the second fight was
you were landing
hard leg kicks in the first fight but
you were landing them on the thigh
and then it switched over to the calf
what what a crazy difference
that calf kick has made in mma over the
last few years
yeah it's really nuts it is man and it
doesn't take many
and it doesn't take as much commitment
you know a thigh kick you're turning
your hips over muay thai style
you're really set in your position
whipping this calf kick you can flick
you know you can flick it like a jab and
just catch the top of the calf and it's
it's so wild that this one kick was
almost ignored i always give benson
henderson credit because i think he was
the first guy to start using in the ufc
but for whatever reason
he didn't have the same impact with it
it just i don't know
i'd have to go over some fights huge
legs i'm sure he gets harder
i'm sure he kicks off yeah but for
whatever reason he wasn't stopping guys
with calf kicks but then
along the way somewhere in the last what
was it five six years or something like
that
not maybe not even that far back maybe
not even which is crazy yeah which is
crazy
i can't think of a thing a single
technique that got that
revolutionized the sport that way right
and then
like i said about the calf you can't
take many because there's nowhere for
the swelling to go so that's why it's so
painful and
debilitating your your nerves and your
foot kind of stopped working with you
it's it's bad stuff yeah there's no meat
there either i was explaining to someone
i'm like just
just karate chop your arm right here
where the bone is
it hurts just to do that now imagine
someone kicking that
and that's what it's like when you get
kicked in the calf there's nothing there
there's no meat and even when you turn
your shin outward to check it
you still get it it's still bad man yeah
well i noticed that in the conner fight
yeah
you could see somewhere in the first
round when he started realizing like oh
this is a real problem
yeah and conor doesn't have the ability
to switch stances or if he does he
doesn't do it
yeah definitely didn't do in that fight
and it was only going to get worse that
was second round you know we had three
more rounds 15 more minutes of me
chopping that leg
yeah if we do it again it'll be
interesting to see what he does uh
different in preparation or by defending
that you know well you were such
such a different guy in the second fight
you know you first of all you weren't
debilitating yourself getting down to
145 pounds yeah
i mean you were a big 145 like how rough
was that cut
it was horrible and it made me hate the
process because my quality of life
sucked
you know training camps were torture you
know uh
i would walk around 190. i'd get up to
190.
i'd get up to one night so crazy yeah oh
my god you get up to 190 and go down to
145.
45 [ __ ] pounds let me tell you this
when i [ __ ] up swanson in london
england i took it on short notice
and i just won a fight before and it was
right around christmas so i was eating
and when they called me uh they asked me
my weight and i told them 170 but i was
like
187 or something and it was like really
short notice so me and my team fly out
there
um i'm 30 pounds over when we land you
know fight week they check
jesus christ oh my god it's so
crazy they check your weight fight week
when you show up to make sure
i was uh i was 176 and it was a 45.
oh my god yeah but you made it made it
how the [ __ ] did you make that i don't
know almost died i don't i feel like
weigh-ins were kind of blurry i don't
like my memories going from weigh-ins
it's it's not good for you do you think
it makes sense though
for you to be fighting conor for the
title no
i don't think so do you think it should
be oliveira
connor's been away so long his last two
fights at 155 he's lost so you can't put
him in there for a title fight
right how could you you know justify
doing that when they got when you have
guys like olivera
but if khabib retires and they say hey
this is for all the marbles you're not
going to say no
what are you going to say you're going
to say i'm a purist
what are you going to say i don't know
if dana pulls you aside he goes it
doesn't have to make
of sense but let's make some money yeah
we're fighting for the belt
yeah you have to fight for the belt yeah
we'll see what happens man i think it's
going to be something soon because we've
got to keep it moving they're not going
to sit forever
chasing khabib and the division has to
move on
it is interesting that in the time where
that low calf kick is coming to
prominence
and you know this is also the time when
conor started moving away from the sport
took time off fought boxing you know
then came back and had the fight with
khabib and then came back and had the
fight with cowboy
the calf kick was never in play in any
of his fights but if you look at him
stylistically and this is one of the
things i love dc's
detail that he does on espn it's amazing
but when he broke down conor's heavy
weight on the right
leg he leans in like this all the time
he puts a lot of weight on that right
leg
when he pause in that southpaw stance
and because you fight southpaw a lot as
well
it just opens up that kick so big it's
such a big weapon
and sometimes like you said that wide
stance as well mm-hmm
it's just hard to check the kick from
that wide stance yeah you know what's a
crazy stance
for everything other than calf kicks
it's a great stance
i mean he's so good at at moving in and
and covering distance with that stance
it's very karate like
great countering like you see karate
bounce back and forth to a boom attack
um and he and he has a hell of a left
hand where he you know he's knocked out
a bunch of guys with it with that
counter with that pull too
and that's what we we worked on a lot
that training camp with my boxing coach
davis is
is that pool too baiting him in to throw
the pool too
yeah the one time when you use one of
the times you caught him several times
but one time we caught him with that
counter right hook
and you pointed at him like i got you
[ __ ] yeah
yeah that felt good i just felt like i
was kind of uh
grabbing the wheel and starting to let
him understand oh this guy's changed you
know
like this isn't the same fight dc also
broke down
at the end of the first round you kind
of gently punched him in the stomach
just gently like hey man good round good
game good round
there was a little there's a little
gamesmanship going on there
i didn't i didn't do it in the moment i
didn't do it like uh like you're
thinking about it yeah it just happened
just natural yeah what did you say to
him at the end of the first round
you said something when we were hitting
each other with the with the shoulders i
was uh having fun asking them
i think i told them how'd you like that
clavicle just messing around
you know that's a funny how did you like
that clavicle i like that clavicle has
anybody ever said that in life that
might be the first time a human being
has said how did you like that clavicle
i delivered one
i think that's probably got me back
better though you think of all the
sentences that people have said
throughout history
that might that clavicle yeah there
might be like two or three other humans
that have ever lived
that have said those words together how
did you like that clavicle
right yeah that's not that's not that's
not the word you phrase you use
often very uncommon phrase how'd you
like to actually like that clavicle
oh man then he started cracking me with
him yeah and
well he had more pop on his for sure the
cowboy fight that was bananas
he was able to do that kind of damage
yeah broke his nose maybe
yeah for sure i mean he was bleeding out
of the nose right away that was nuts
a lot of people didn't even understand
what was happening i wonder why uh
because when he started hitting me with
them i just naturally felt like i just
put my head on the other side
yeah here it is
well it's a it's obviously something
that he's practiced yeah
the one of the things about this fight
is you look like the bigger guy
i i'm pretty sure i weighed more than
him
yeah you looked like it you look more
muscular he's uh
you know he's muscular but his waist is
small he's just built
just built different and i just i'll
probably walk around heavier than him
do you feel like now after that first
fight that you got his number
or after the second fight it's uh it's
fighting man i don't think you ever
really
he'll make adjustments yeah he'll make
adjustments it'll be a completely
different fight like the first one in
the second was different the third one's
going to be different as well
because i'm going to make adjustments as
well i got to switch it up and
keep things fresh and keep him guessing
yeah
now in ideally when would you like to
rematch
june july june july because i'm still
my wife's birthday's coming up so we're
going to go somewhere for a couple days
like i'm still not
i will if if i get the call and it's
time to go to work
i will lock myself in training camp but
uh
i'm still not right now ready to just go
back to florida a month removed from
from the last fight
and then lock down for another 10 weeks
or whatever it is so we'll see
if they call i will do it but i would
i'd rather it be a little bit further
let me enjoy my life
uh back home in louisiana before i go
right back out to florida so if they
call you and say man you will be doing
it but you would rather yeah
i'll do it anytime i would be shocked if
they decided to do it in may just
that close after that ko i just don't
think that's wise
yeah it is soon yeah and and obviously
i mean honestly it's not it's not a lot
of time to adjust and work on
what we need what he needs to work on
for the calf kick or what i want to
switch up you know
we're just right back in camp getting
ready to fight we're not really
evolving outside of training camp for me
i learn things in training camp because
it's just constant every day under
pressure
but it's the the time between camps like
right now when i'm in the gym having fun
rolling and doing slight kickboxing
drills with my friends where i feel like
the big gains are made when i'm having
fun
because i'm kind of tunnel vision and
training camp i'm showing up all right
let's wrestle all right i'm not having
fun and exploring different things
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience